[Musique]
une cabane à sucre dans les années 50
avec une récolte de l'eau d'érable à
cheval
le repas traditionnel à l'extérieur avec
jambon crêpe et oreilles de crise le
tout trempé dans le sirop d'érable
et surtout la tire d'érable sur la neige
aux délice
au début des années 60 il y a eu une
forme de modernisation de la collecte de
l'eau d'érable avec des véhicules à
chenilles qui venaient remplacer les
traîneaux à chevaux
des cabanes aussi plus performantes avec
un meilleur équipement
[Musique]
à faire à force
les hommes pour faire le sirop et les
femmes pour préparer les friandises au
sucre desrables
et pourquoi pas en profiter pour faire
une danse entre amis
ou encore une balade nocturne en
véhicule à chenille dans les rabelières
la sève de l'érable à sucre a été
découverte il y a très longtemps par les
Abenakis et les Micmacs entre autres
dans les forêts de l'Est comme nous le
rappelle cette émission de Radio-Canada
imaginez ce qui pouvait bien se passer
dans la tête de nos ancêtres la toute
première fois lorsque les Amérindiens
les ont amenés dans la forêt afin de
leur offrir ce merveilleux cadeau
[Musique]
s'occuper
de faire spécialement de ceux des rap et
puis avec le table comment les gens se
sont rangés du côté des abrédiens après
comment ils vivaient
et la tradition c'est perpétuée jusqu'à
nos jours dans des cabanes spacieuses
avec une nourriture abondante et où il
fait bon se retrouver sans oublier comme
dessert la fameuse tire sur la neige
au Québec plus de 1000 entreprises assez
récoltes offrent du sirop ou des
produits certifiés biologiques le sirop
d'érable fait même partie de l'identité
culturelle et gastronomique québécoises
il y a même une classification du sirop
d'érable selon la couleur et le goût une
classification qui va du doré au goût
délicat ou très foncé au goût prononcé
le temps des sucres c'est aussi
l'occasion de célébrer une belle période
de l'année
[Musique]
Radio-Canada Montréal